colin ray will pitch for the cubs this
afternoon there's yellows
bouncing ball right side shallow right
field glove by jason kipnis and he
throws out yelich at a very promising
first inning rock adrian hauser getting
the call here yeah he's been good his
first three starts have been very good
rizzo one four seven two walks and a run
knocked into the series and a high drive
deep left yelich on the track it is gone
rizzo makes it one nothing in the first
that's number five on the season
for tony two chains
back to back two out three passes here's
ian half batting left-handed hits one
down the left-field line slicing away
from yelich that's in there for a base
hit one run is in racing to third on the
play contreras it's a double for half
and the cubs leave two to nothing brian
braun with two outs and the base is
empty in the second
ron stings one into left center field
that's going to find the gap and get to
the wall
and cruising in with a two out double is
ryan wrong eric soulguard
on the ground rizzo will head to the bag
kipnis will throw and they got him out
wow that's a great adjustment by both
guys cubs have the leadoff man on
leading two to nothing in the second
inning but is though at the plate
that'll get in for his second hit of the
day let's see if kittness can score
garcia cuts it off kipnis around third
and he's in and it's three to nothing
line drive base hit left center this
might be an extra bass knock for hap
he's racing around first he'll have an
easy double as yelich gets to the ball
and gets it back in and ian half just
like rizzo has his second extra base hit
of the day
here's victor caratini
bouncing ball
this will end the inning as ureas takes
care of it
one one from colin ray and hira pops it
up
rizzo over near the barrier and he's got
rome
a little quick look there by rizzo to
see where he was brewers have him on the
corners with one out
one swing of the bat and we get to start
over
and smoke sends one in the air left
center field that's going to find the
gap that's down yelich is in garcia
rounding third he's being waved around
in a two-run double from justin smoke
and the brewers get their first couple
of runs of the game pitching change ryan
topera the new man on the mound
brewers have gone single single two-run
double and now a walk to brawn
is the banner luisa rias with a ground
ball in the hole and through by as a
base hit here comes smoke and this game
is tied two outs and nobody on for
anthony rizzo who's been a tough out
for hauser here this afternoon pitch
lined and still cone by sogard as he
climbs the ladder
and makes the catch to end the inning
what a play by eric sogard sadler the
new right-handed pitcher for the cubs
here's braun he's reached twice
back in there today as he rips one down
the line and left and that's going to
get to the corner ryan braun will have
his second double of the day
and he has reached all three times
and now first and second and a big
opportunity for orlando archie
3-2 delarcia on the ground infield in it
sneaks through braun is in
as the brewers take the lead rbi single
from arcia
it's 4-3 brew crew one down here's
anthony rizzo
rizzo again with good contact and he's
on with a single
he's a triple shy of the cycle
at first two outs seventh inning and
schwarber with a line drive base hit
to get the tying run to second base
has walked struck out and bounced to the
pitcher
[Applause]
the back pedal ureas
two hands on it and the cubs strand a
couple suitor two scoreless innings
swinging a fly ball right field long run
hayward still going back he went on the
run he makes the catch
hayward on the dead run on the warning
track right in front of the 368 marker
he got a good jump and made a very nice
running catch to end the inning
corey knable
to steven souza in a fly ball toward the
left field corner and it is gone
a home run
just inside the pole
we are tied
what a dramatic moment for souza here's
a former cub david phelps he's trying to
get this game into the 10th inning
bryant with a base hit to start it
winning run is on base with nobody out
here is baez
up the middle behind the bag the flip
and they're gonna turn it oh he beat it
a lunge at the very end
so baez at first and the batters
schwarber
javi goes
call strike three doesn't matter
schwarber strikes out the cubs don't
score we go to the 10th inning
and remember the new format each team
will begin their half inning with a
runner at second base
il garcia
shoots one into right field toward the
corner and that is down a fair ball
yelts will score garcia into second and
it's 5-4 brewers in the 10. justin smoke
betting
slicing drive caught by half ian hat
just brought justin smoke
i want to play this a spectacular play
you talk about a gutsy play
he doesn't come up with that it's going
all the way to the wall brewers have
them on the corners one strike pitch
bouncing ball in the hole by as a
sliding stop but no play garcia's in and
an infield rbi single for ureas his
third hit of the game and it's six to
four brewers ramora advanced to third
now it's ian happ right-handed ian
bounced to third no look and almora will
score
two down a one-run game
holds of all two strikes here it comes
and the brewers win it alex
claudio shuts the door on the cubs and
the brewers in back-to-back games
did one-run victories what a good one to
hear today